[Music]
mumbai has over 18 million people
the city it's unpredictable
but amidst this chaos there is one thing
that is nearly 100 reliable
it's your lunch delivery
[Music]
the dubba wallas of mumbai are an
institution
a double willa is a guy who delivers
homemade
this is how the system works
the double walla comes to your home and
picks up your lunch
he goes to the train station where all
the other lunches are they are sorted
and then delivered out into the city to
be dropped off at your office you eat it
the double wallet comes picks it up and
brings your lunchbox back home that's
the key word home these aren't takeout
delivery guys they're delivering you a
meal straight from your kitchen
this system while seemingly rudimentary
has been recognized as one of the most
efficient logistics systems in the world
double wallets have an accuracy of 99.9
percent in their deliveries per million
transactions less than four mistakes are
made
important
to
[Music]
[Music]
crossing side streets on bikes balancing
trays that weigh almost 150 pounds on
their head this group of five thousand
men they helped define the city
yesterday
these guys are out there six days a week
monsoon or shine life in mumbai it can
be chaotic your train might be late your
power might go out but damn it your
lunch will be on time
you